- I hope I remember this, oh God.
- Gotta get my arms.
- Oh, you're awesome.
(electronic music)
- Are you ready?
Let's do it.
♪ I'm a Lamborghini ♪
♪ I'm a Hollywood star ♪
♪ I'm a little bit tipsy ♪
♪ When I drive my car ♪
♪ I'm expensive sushi ♪
♪ I'm a cute, cute shot ♪
♪ I'm a little bit single ♪
♪ Even when I'm not ♪
♪ Ah ah ♪
♪ I'm a little bit ♪
♪ I'm a classic Bronco ♪
♪ I'm on Texas time ♪
♪ I'm a whole lotta tipsy ♪
♪ When I drink fine wine ♪
♪ I got like 20 jobs ♪
♪ And I talk a lot ♪
♪ I'm a whole lot married ♪
♪ My man's so hot ♪
(audience cheering)
♪ I'm a little bit ♪
♪ I'm a whole lot ♪
♪ La la la la la la la ♪
♪ A little bit Alexis ♪
♪ And a whole lot of Texas ♪
♪ Hide your diamonds ♪
♪ Hide your exes ♪
♪ I'm a little bit Alexis ♪
(audience cheering)
- I love you so much.
- Oh my God.